32 ein und will kann hierbei wie
schnecken lieblings format im internet
wird beim web heute machen wie cocktails
sowie letztes mal aus sex and the city
den cosmopolitan den weltberühmten also
es gibt bei sex and the city ist glaube
ich eine million szenen wo sie in der
bar sitzen im restaurant immer haben sie
diesen typischen pink roten cocktail in
der hand für den kosmopoliten brauchen
wir konnten
ich bin von keiner marke gesponsert auch
das letzte video nicht dieses video
nicht
das sind einfach die einzigen alkohol
marken die das produkt hiermit brauch
ich glaube das ist ein organischer likör
ja dann brauchen wir die quelle des
lebens mein baby saft und zu guter letzt
werden
das sieht schon besser aus als der james
bond lang bestimmte sie mehr gewusst und
alle leute die da draußen schon mal sex
and the city geschaut haben ob den film
wurde jetzt die serie egal ob die ich
auch mal das gefühl jetzt an die mädels
die jungs natürlich auch dass man so
eine freundesgruppe haben möchte so
mädels mit denen man sich immer wieder
trifft zwar mit des schaurigen so mann
ich hab dir das auch mal versteckt wo es
michaela brauche noch ein paar
erfolgreiche mädels in berlin den möchte
ich so luxuriöse sachen machen
das ist auch so fähig wenn man so eine
serie schaut wo alle viel geld haben und
keiner hat geldsorgen sondern nur so
sorgen
ich werde nicht oft genug geknabbert
mister big ist online auf und die ganz
normale leute new york so bezahle ich
meine miete money money money money
[Musik]
ich war so lange nicht mehr hier was
passiert auf meinem kanal
ich frage mich ob das positiv oder
negativ mal war ich glaube negativ
gemeint als grundlage machen natürlich
gemacht
wir brauchen 23
hallo mein kanal schon auch kinder so
kinder jetzt zeige ich euch was mama
macht die richtige stress ist okay 1 tl
orangenlikör control ist ein guter
barkeeper hat natürlich seid obst und
gemüsesaft vorbereitet saft von einer
limette morgen 1 dl limettensaft vieles
kompliziert und zu schwach ohne zwang
ist einem fitnessstudio natürlich ist
also hilfe anstrengt gerade war ich
wollte wissen woher diese zitronenpresse
haben hansa toren sage man sicher vorbei
cool aus es ist ein anstrengender studio
[Musik]
jetzt kann man natürlich noch dekorativ
da den limetten shirt oder im garten
arbeiten sind jeweils sechs minister die
gewinne stiegen die mieten statt da drin
hatten
ich weiß nicht wie man es macht und das
mit limetten halt also und wünsche hat
natürlich wird er aller wichtigsten
fragen
nein freunde in dem ich diesen sieg
genießen kann und wie schmeckt der
cosmopolitan aus existiert leute aus
happy halloween irgendwann dann mal kann
deshalb sehr von james bond sehr viel
alkohol die gefeller aber wie kühler ist
eigentlich möchte ich mal so musste ich
noch so eine warnung hinstellen
wisst ihr was kinder an die supertolle
binge trinken die ersten 18 trinken
[Musik]
die sind über meine freundinnen carrie
weil es auch wenn viele etwas für die
frauen gibt die sich meiner gruppe
anschließen wollen von coolen leuten
dann bewerbt euch unter dem video
ich starte ein format in dem ich auch
die jetzt trinke und mit frauen über sex
reden und ich nenne es sex in the city
ich möchte ein format haben oder ein
podcast indem ich über sex reden
ich werde niemals so witzig sein wie
ines an juli mit wie heißt der podcast
ist schluss dann kriegt so achim fest
wir sind sechs schwestern habe selbst
schwestern und wir haben sechs airbags
auch ein anderer podcast hessen
flauschig das bin ich basics danke an
die assistenz produktionsleitung das
licht kamera ton auf euch danke für die
hilfe
es wäre so cool wenn es ein großes
produktionsteam hätte alle würden
setzen uns aber macht das total super
ist der finger oben sieht man dich logen
und damit sage ich tschüss ich hoffe
euch hatten die folge gefallen wenn ja
hans zach ist mir unbedingt nach oben
das hilft mir weiter aber nicht meinen
kanal und keine weitere mädels zu
verpassen aktiviert die glocke um keine
videos mehr zu verpassen folgt auf
twitter und kannst meine videos neu dazu
verpassen
instagram um mir zu sagen die rücksicht
bin und da verabschiede ich mich meine
damen und herren mein name ist bushido
ich hoffe euch hat die show gefallen
sind die endes geht es um ihren hals
lassen sich bestechen